بدورها اعلنت نقابه اطباء السودان عن
ارتفاع عدد ضحايا المدنيين منذ بدايه
الاشتباكات الى
243 قتيلا
و1,335 مصابا وافادت نقابه بارتفاع عدد
المستشفيات المتوقفه عن العمل في الخرطوم
وولايات اخرى الى خمسه وخمسين من اصل 78
وفي اليوم السادس من القتال تعرضت اربعه
مستشفيات في الابيض للقصف مما يرفع العدد
الكلي الى 13 انما تعرض 19 مستشفى للاخلاء
القصري
وقالت النقابه ان ثلاثه وعشرين مستشفى من
اصل 78 اصبح مهددا بالاغلاق بسبب نقص
الكوادر الطبيه وانقطاع الخدمات الاساسيه
وفي مقابله مع الجزيره وصف عطيه عبد الله
عطيه سكرتير نقابه الاطباء السودان
الاوضاع الطبيه بالمتدهوره للغايه اضاف
عطيه ان 11 طبيبا قتل منذ بدء المعارك
السبت الماضي وحذر المواطنين من التوجه
الى المستشفيات التي تعرضت للقصف ومن
التجمعات كما نشد المجتمع الدولي ضروره
التدخل لوقف الاقتتال
هنالك ازدياد في اعداد المستشفيات التي
خرجت خارج الخدمه وايضا الصفات التي تم
قصها وصل الى 13 مستشفى ايضا نحن الان
نتحدث عن فقط
اساسي في العاصمه والولايات يستطيع تقديم
الخدمه الوضع الانساني والطبي سيء للغايه
حتى هذه المستشفيات التي نتحدث عنها هي
مستشفيات اساسيه يمكنها التقديم الخدمه
الطبيه للجرحى والمصابين هذه المستشفيات
هي على حافه الاغلاق في اي لحظه ينقصها
عدد من المعينات ايضا انقطاع الماء التيار
المائي والكهربائي يهدد عمليات غسيل الكلى
وايضا يهدد وجود المرضى المنويه في هذه
المستشفيات نحن ارسلنا عدد من النداءات
الى الضغط على الطرفي الصراع لوقتها للحب
العباسيه فورا وفتح ممرات امنه